una nueva guerra verbal en el conflicto
pesquero parís está furiosa por la falta
de avances en londres para que los
pescadores franceses obtengan las
licencias en aguas británicas las
tensiones en torno al acuerdo post break
sheet podrían dar lugar ahora a
sanciones de parís dos copas nuestra
paciencia está llegando al límite hay
una voluntad evidente que se ha
expresado de no respetar el acuerdo y no
dar a nuestros pescadores que han sido
muy pacientes que han esperado durante
mucho tiempo que han sido ejemplares las
licencias a las que tienen derecho
concretamente francia amenaza con
intensificar los controles fronterizos y
sanitarios de las mercancías británicas
e impedir que los barcos pesqueros
británicos accedan a determinados
puertos franceses y reforzar los
controles de los camiones que entran y
salen de reino unido el ministerio
marítimo francés y el ministerio de
asuntos exteriores europeos afirmaron en
un comunicado que se está preparando una
segunda ronda de medidas francia no
descarta revisar su suministro de
energía a reino unido por su parte el
ministro británico para el break it loud
y sostuvo en una declaración que las
amenazas de francia son decepcionantes y
desproporcionadas y no lo que cabría
esperar de un aliado y socio cercano las
medidas con las que están amenazando no
parecen ser compatibles con el acuerdo
de comercio y cooperación post break
sheet y el derecho internacional más
amplio la disputa se centra en la
concesión de licencias para pescar en
aguas territoriales de 6 a 12 millas
náuticas en las costas británicas de
reino unido y las islas de alrededor del
canal francia se ha molestado
especialmente por el rechazo de los
barcos franceses en las aguas cercanas a
ghersi y hershey al lado del suelo
francés el enfrentamiento por la pesca
es solo uno más en una serie de
desacuerdos entre londres y parís las
relaciones diplomáticas entre los dos
países están en su punto más bajo en
décadas con sabor a australia el primer
ministro scott morrison aseguró no poder
comprometerse a reducir las emisiones de
carbono en ese país en un 30% para final
de la década el anuncio llega antes de
que morrison acuda a la cumbre de
convenirse donde los países expondrán
objetivos climáticos escuchamos
es un objetivo de reducción de emisiones
de toda la economía lo que hemos dicho
muy claramente sin embargo es que no
estamos suscribiendo la solicitud de
metano 2030 y esa es en realidad una
posición bipartidista y lo dejamos muy
claro y eso se ha informado hoy también
hemos dicho muy claramente que según
nuestro plan no impondremos en ningún
mandato a los agricultores no nos
dirigiremos a ellos de ninguna manera
como parte de nuestro plan de reducción
de emisiones